[Music]
welcome to air biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm Linc this week at the round table of
dim lighting we are tackling the
question what is our relationship with
gross foods oh we have a relationship
with gross foods we have a mess news to
me I don't know if you know but we also
have a an audio-visual program that
comes out five days a week called good
mythical morning oh man we've done it
I'm gonna I've kind of traced our
relationship with food through the
episodes of the show like of Oz what oh
no not like Shabazz but you should tell
people what you mean by that well
whenever I hear the word trace this is a
this is a sauce just absolutely named in
my brain
Shabazz moved to Buies Creek what great
probably six seventh grade maybe yeah it
was definitely eighth grade he was there
because at the eighth grade parties
partying Adam Nicholson's house I was
gonna say fifth but okay oh yeah he
could have been there earlier but I know
he was in our friend group in eighth
grade because he would come to the
parties but Shabazz all of a sudden like
you know when you're that age it's like
the ability to draw is is like a social
you got points you everybody knows the
kids who can draw you know what I'm
saying it's like being able to draw us a
oh yeah mark he's a really good draw in
grade school there's an expectation that
everyone should draw and then sadly some
people are actually good at it that's
weaned out of people but then by the
time you get to later middle school
which i think is where this story takes
place so this this this memory there's
just a few people who continue to draw
like Kevin Kevin wins
he continued to draw right I think he
can take continues to draw because he's
good at drawing but anyways Shabazz was
breaking out these incredible renditions
of like Warner Brothers characters and
comic book characters and bringing them
Gulen really who what this guy this new
guy is incredible
yeah and I don't know who discovered it
but Shabazz was tracing he got out like
the secret got out it got out he was
traced basically plagiarism it's visual
plagiarism this had much more of an
impact on you than me I think he was in
he must have been in your class not mine
I don't know man it's just I think I
because when you hear the web we're a so
intimidated by I'm intimidated by people
who are better at things than me and I
want to draw - and so I was just mad at
him you know like when Shay Mitchell was
so great at tasting I think yeah very
similar yeah I wouldn't have that came
out of me and an anger that was then
validated when I found out that she was
tracing so to say given the freakin
answers but yeah that's why when I hear
tracing I think it's your Bozz it I will
all wait when you hear the word with the
word tracing that was quite an aside
when I hear the word Tracy oh I think of
yep I think of Tracy yeah me too who we
went to high school with and she had a
she had an older boyfriend who was a
real cowboy
Shane uh no he had like a crew-cut and
he was blond hair he was a real cowboy
yeah yeah he had like he had boots and
he used him right like a belt buckle
tuck his shirt in yeah she was in my
typing class and I kind of flirted with
her but I wasn't her type because I
didn't I didn't was that a joke no it
was I didn't even know I said it are you
intimidated by how well I can throw puns
out there without even yeah angry makes
you feel like makes me feel like you're
tracing you're tracing your comedy
so I've traced how we got to the point
in good mythical morning
where were we consumed so much food we
do III have to believe we have a
different relationship with food because
of the way we eat so much gross stuff
and just food in general so I'll come
back to that there was some fascinating
things in that timeline that I that
surprised me at least when I Shabazz dit
so we can come back to that that's a
good use also I have some interesting
tidbits about what makes things that are
typically not tasty something that you
might acquire a taste for like the the
psychology behind what I'll call
acquiring a taste for something hmm
especially when it comes to hot peppers
and gross things and it extends beyond
just foods as well so I'm prepared if it
comes to it to also talk about that
because in my mind that's what led up to
that was a starting point for this
conversation and also Alex asking us how
has our relationship with food changed
because of the show I was like that's a
good question we'll talk about that okay
but first we're gonna just catch up on
the fact that we are both about to head
out of town yeah we're obviously we're
gonna be in at the time of recording
this will be in London next week for
VidCon doing our doing our VidCon
appearance and also our show our concert
but we wouldn't that was weird how you
said at the time of recording this well
we will not be in London we're here
we're reporting I corrected myself at
the time of recording we will be in
London next week okay that's how I
completed my Senna's as of right now
when we're speaking once we're done
recording this podcast we're both
leaving on independent vacations and
then right on the backside of that we're
going to London by the time you listen
to this we'll be back from all of that
and then you can expect I guess if it's
worthy of a podcast we'll probably give
you each other in you an update on our
vacations but I mean I'm in like have I
forgotten something important like a
passport or or my are my underwears
clean type of thing and what are the
main things that I need because there's
so I stripped those short trips I'm just
taking a long weekend to make oh I'm
going to Cabo because you've already
been and I thought that was a good idea
are you I'm not taking my kids do you
need the watermelon outfit well I still
have it because I don't need it where
I'm going
III should take it to Cabo I was
thinking about when I took that for
Instagram Chris he was like you should
wait till we go to cabo I gotta come
back now I got to do it here and like it
was raining it was it was kind of like a
polar opposite a little bit which
interestingly is kind of what's
happening with our mini vacations here
because the place that I'm going I
looked at the weather last night and it
was currently one degree Fahrenheit one
degree Fahrenheit what what okay
that's thirty-one below zero Fahrenheit
it's mammoth well it's not again it's
not 31 degrees below zero 31 below
freezing frizzy Fahrenheit the yeah I'm
going out to Mammoth interestingly have
you been there yeah well last year so
it's a ski mountain I've never been this
is your second time it is I think it's
the largest ski resort in California
it's definitely the highest elevation so
it gets the most snow and they just got
10 feet over the past weekend 10 feet
that's a basketball goal that's crazy
yeah that is nuts man it was a blizzard
it was nuts are you gonna be able to get
there I mean yeah you're leaving
basically hours from now first thing in
the morning well I mean everything is
hours from now it's just a matter of how
many Wow all things aren't you
philosophical all things in the future
or hours from now listen if you keep if
you keep talking that smack I'm not
gonna let you borrow my with my rooftop
cargo I I'm not taking it I don't need
it
oh so that's why no what because Locke
sprained his ankle he's asking Jesse had
already made a decision that she was not
going to ski and that she was just gonna
chill and read okay and so that leaves
me and Shep and so the only reason I
need the rooftop carrier is to get the
skis back and forth from the where we
rented them because we're staying at a
place where we can just walk out and
then like walk to the lifts so wasn't
that's I believe that this I you don't
if you don't want my carry don't have it
I mean I'll take it it's not like I'll
take if you won which it's not like it's
I didn't get the best carrier based on
Amazon review
but getting exist I'm worried about
largest capacity gas mileage hey you
know what about the get it's not like
it's the most aerodynamic rooftop
carrier that exists have you you haven't
driven so half you don't have to borrow
half way to Mammoth yeah my feelings
aren't hurt when you get to the southern
end of the Sierra Nevadas the wind is
ridiculous like I'm afraid that the
rooftop carrier I just end up on the
side of the road sideways right off the
side but the main reason just don't need
it because Shepherds got short skis I
got long skis it'll be in there for a
half I'm not taking it personally uh but
I'm gonna be freezing you're gonna be
livin it up oh I'm gonna be freezing
yeah no sprained ankles but I have no
children at all I am excited about I'm
excited about skiing and hopefully I'll
have a some kind of story not too
harrowing because one of the things I
read was there's something that there's
something that the mammoth website they
were like you know beware of something
something something basically falling
into deep snow and suffocating oh
there's a term out of that ten feet of
snow and so because you know how it is
the one time we went with Eric yeah - I
guess it was a Park City Park City and
it was snow as like a blizzard while we
were on the mountain if you go off the
like the groomed or the paths like he
was trying to take us through little
shortcuts but if you really don't know
how to ski well that's crazy it might
fall under the the stood of the powder
and then you cannot get out there's an
art to like staying on top of the powder
I like the groomed man I love a blue man
you got to be like a Legolas in Lord of
the Rings looks like I'm like Blue Man
Group on the slopes I see the blue and I
go for it I don't the bus stay away from
the Black Diamond so I don't like the
slopes I like the gentle gentle paths
through the trees
you like percussion on like found items
yep that's really what time is show in
Vegas it's just me going through the
trees I thought about taking Jade with
Christina on our pre Valentine's
romantic weekend in Cabo before I head
away to actually be apart from my wife
and the love of my life when Valentine
proper hits I'll be entertaining
mythical beasts in London which by the
way if you want to come see us go to
rhett and Link live.com to see where
we're going to show up but a place near
you around the u.s. we have some other
dates posted and we're doing music we're
doing a bonafide concert there is
costuming involved at a certain point
right and we continue to announce dates
for as those things fall into place and
I'll just go ahead and do some more
plugging while we're at it if you
remember of the mythical Society you
actually are the first to find out about
where we're playing so you can get those
tickets those get to good seats get the
VIP tix
that kind of thing that goes to the
mythical Society first so I'm trying to
figure out if I should take Jade as a
last minute decision just because the
answer's no I like I just mentioned it
to Christy I wasn't like I want to bring
Jade this is about mean you and I I do
understand that so I never didn't say
any that all I said was well you know
the hotel allows dogs I just left it at
that she was like I know but we don't
need to bring Jay because this is about
us and I was like exactly Yeah right I'm
just like you know it's just a fact I
mean to me let you know other people's
dogs will be there just in case you want
to bring your dog repel I just find I
just think it's a fun idea to fly with a
dog to bring a dog to another like a
hotel and like why is that a fun idea I
mean you'd have an unusually what she
does you have an unusually right now and
even know it but I but even how even
though she's so easy
she's like a fanny pack without the
strap but she's still a little she sits
there on my body burden because she
wants your attention yeah that's true
it's again I don't want to do it I want
it just to be me and Christy and well
you have it had the dog at the pool with
you that would be kind of cool now being
that guy be like dr. evil or something
having my my cat with me at all that
well yeah okay I haven't seen those
movies but I think that's what happens
in him I think you're talking about
Inspector gadgets doesn't arch-nemesis
maybe daughter Eva as a kid I can't
remember I'm bad as everybody tells I
haven't seen it but I
as a cat so anyway so far we're gonna
move on to everything we've already
talked about but just in summary we've
devoted this podcast that you're
listening to to what might happen in
other podcasts that will tell you about
let's say that's what we've done so far
well we've just we've basically teased
other episodes that we don't even know
will exist it's like this is what's
gonna happen in our lives if there's
something to report best believe this is
the venue that it will be report
analyzing as well as our prop I probably
will have posted lots of stuff on my
Instagram shout out to me on Instagram
link Lamarr or you can do that no that's
good I'm really I'm really gaining
momentum over there mm-hmm
yeah you're calling quite a pace but do
you know what I'm just dancing like no
one's watching so let's get to that food
stuff in a minute but first we do want
to let you know that you can procure the
sweater or sweatshirt that I have on and
the baseball shirt that link is wearing
now yours this looks like a black this
is long-sleeve a spin sweatshirt
actually especially in the dim lighting
if I do that kind of reveal that oh
there's a little surprise in there and
it's it's the mythical logo it's very
very cool you have the mythical logo as
well I do got a mythical dot store and
get all types of stuff all types of
surprises rip us connect with other
mythical beasts out there in the wild
when they see those rub your boys rip
you Ballet's yeah we should get that
would do irreparable damage oh gosh bye
repping your boys mythical dot store
okay I'm interested to talk talk about
because I emotional mmm-hmm I'm speaking
of food I've got some almonds that are
still in my throat in the back some salt
vinegar which interestingly enough the
reason I like the salt and vinegar is
because they bite you a little bit they
get they give you a little bit of a bite
that's right you know that you're eating
them mm-hmm yeah there's there is a
mouth punch but this has come up that
possibly a child if they were to eat one
would be Republic Sultan vinegary unless
they have acquired that taste this is
what I'm gonna get into you me start
there what do you want to start that's
fine well I was going to say that this
is a question that I feel like I get I'm
sure you get it as well from just any
time I'm eating with someone who is a
friend or at least knows that enough
about our show to know that we weird
stuff on our show I feel like there's
this this expectation that well yeah
sure order that because Brett's here
because he you know he's known for
eating anything has it happened to you I
like there's a while I'm eating with
people at restaurants there's cut there
are conversations about my you know get
gastro exploits that's one word I think
it's very clear that I don't like a lot
of the things that I consume on the show
so I don't run into you know things like
oh you're good we can order that because
usually link'll like we can't order that
because links here that's a different
that's a different say I'm trying to
there was
somebody was having a conversation in it
it was like something some weird
combination of foods or like oh we could
try that's something to try you know
what
wouldn't it be fun to try that and then
they realized they were talking to me
and they're like oh I'm sorry I you just
counted your job you know right maybe it
was Britain at the house like we were
just hanging out he like caught himself
I can't remember who it was honestly I
just I erased it from my memory because
it was I wasn't in work mode but yeah I
do think there's this oh yeah I'm even
with with friends and whenever any of
that like weird food stuff comes up the
conversation takes a different
complexion because I feel like that
somehow we found ourselves in a position
of being these the guys who eat stuff on
the internet that is a facet that is a
facet that is not me as a whole person
so let's come back to that but let's
start more with like the psychology and
the science and this other podcast that
I was looking for a new podcast like
browsing seen what I could listen to
you'd listen to all of our ear biscuits
back so many times you just couldn't
take it anymore you had to get something
else i I found a podcast called hidden
brain it's an NPR podcast I'll try to
remember to tweet out a link to it but
you can search anywhere podcasts are
found not a sponsor it's just it's
explorations in what happens in in the
brain and how that impacts our daily
lives I've only listened to one episode
and it is an episode called radio replay
I guess that means that it was on NPR
and then they put it on the podcast
again at a later date yum yum yum and
yuk is the actual name of the episode
and I highly recommend listening to it
it's very entertaining but you know it I
was like they're gonna talk about eating
nasty stuff I want to see what their
take on this is and there's some
psychological studies and then this guy
the guest they had on there has done
studies and one in particular is about
how well he was talking about people
eating hot peppers and he went to a
particular town in Mexico I believe I'm
remembering this correctly and he was
kind of exploring the subject there
where in this particular place they
treat hot chili peppers like I treat
salt and pepper
mostly pepper like I will I will douse
something in pepper I just like it I
like the black specks like adds a pop of
contrast and then it adds a pop of not
spiciness but a different type of pepper
in my mouth but a chili pepper is a
totally different thing I mean there is
pain associated with eating a chili
pepper and everybody eats them in mass
quantities like it's like it's not a
choice it's just understood and
thoroughly enjoyed by everyone once you
reach the age of five
years old okay sometimes as early as two
so like two to five years old they start
to like chili peppers now before that
you can't give a you can't give a baby
or a nun a climatic four year old a
chili pepper and they're gonna like it
right that's just not gonna happen but
from across the board as a true
statement by that by five years old
they're all eating the Chili Peppers he
was trying to figure out why and he
started looking at the now just to
clarify yeah this is him I would assume
that this is much of Mexico that this
applies to yes I see yes well he
happened to be in this one town and
that's what I was getting at what he did
was he there's a lot of their dogs and
pigs around that are eating the food
that's thrown out which is laced in
chili peppers so his question was have
have they acquired a taste and an
enjoyment of chili peppers as well so
like he put out crack a cracker with
some hot sauce on it and then a cracker
without it to see which one random dogs
and pigs would what would prefer and do
you what's your guess my guess is that
they did not prefer the spicy correct
they did not prefer the spicy now they
ended up eating both of them because
they're animals and they're hungry and
they're gonna eat both but they but they
preferred the ones that weren't spicy
they just tolerate it whereas humans do
something different once they get once
they get to us that age of five years
old or so they're actually starting to
prefer it now the first reason was
described as societal and social
pressure I mean you you're all gathered
around for a meal and all the older
people older siblings they're all eating
the Chili Peppers and even though it's a
painful tear-jerking experience and
that's not something that would apply to
dogs it's something that these peer
pressure is not a thing in the canine
world
I mean probably write some in some way
it is but not with eating hot stuff
right so you know it's it's not actually
an acquired taste like the more you eat
then you start to prefer it but in
humans you they start to prefer it if
given the option of putting the Chili
Peppers on it they will do that they
won't go so to speak to the cracker that
doesn't have it yeah so what's the
difference there what's happening
so the societal pressure to overcome the
initial pain kind of breaks the seal and
you start eating the Chili Peppers but
then the dogs and the pigs inform us to
say well even once you eat it it's still
not an acquired taste there's something
else going on well okay so let me at
this point before you get into the what
is going on mm-hmm
I'm gonna give you just my layman's I'm
not trying to guess where the science is
going I'm just gonna say as someone who
likes hot stuff or liked hot stuff okay
okay cuz something changed with me and
also someone interesting who has a son
who Locke was eating hot wings as early
as I can remember like when he could
have and it was not me telling him son
you should eat this because Shepherd
doesn't like Shepherd still doesn't like
hot stuff hmm Shepherd and less than two
years ago still described toothpaste too
spicy so this is a different palate
yeah but Lando calls Lucroy spicy water
right so cuz it's fizzy but Locke
enjoyed hot wings and would get like
even what you know he's always 14 now
and that we were living at Sherman Oaks
and he was like seven eight nine so even
younger than Shepherd he we would go and
get hot wings but I remember that we
used to get we used to get Zaxby's back
in North Carolina yeah you know so
anyway which had different levels of hot
and he would get he was going on the hot
air very very hot and then of course
once he got to be like 10 or 11 he would
go all the way to where I would went
which i think is like nuclear or
something like that at Saxbys I stopped
eating that stuff because over the past
couple years something has happened
where it effects
like stomach way too much like I love I
don't care about burning mouth I love
the feel and the taste but it's the way
it's affecting my insides it's caused in
my skin I have like breakouts and stuff
anyway
too much detail too much detail rat but
you're veering off to me I always just
thought eh
I would have said that it had more
flavor right so I would I would have
said that the spicy has more flavor
which I believe is a indisputable fact
when it comes to a hot wing like when
you get like mild at a place it just
tastes like butter you know what I'm
saying like if you get like mild buffalo
butter is a flavor I mean I'm just gonna
say it's a different it is a different
experience right but I wouldn't I mean I
just wouldn't say that it doesn't have
the flavor it just has it doesn't have
as much flavor of the type of flavor
that I'm going for but then it does get
into this place that like there's an
experience of eating the eating the hot
wings is like something not it's
memorable it's it's super active if
you're doing it with somebody you're
talking about it it's just it makes much
more it makes much more out of the meal
so you end up just thinking I like hot
stuff it adds a fun element right it's
fun to eat hot stuff well and that that
may be baked into the answer that I
learned from the hidden brain which they
they then began to describe something
that the phrase coined as benign
masochism which is enjoying initially
negative experiences that the body slash
brain falsely interprets as threatening
so it's something it's experiencing pain
from something that is not actually
going to inflict real damage it's
something that's thrilling but not
actually threatening so that experience
of knowing that it hurts but that you're
totally going to be fine
is is whew fuels the
the brain creates an experience that you
want to continue to have almost like
after you if you're like in a if you're
in an accident and then you walk away
from it there's a thrill that's like an
extreme example of that well I better
example is a roller cola coasters before
we didn't use that term but I'm a schism
but that's where that's why I said
that's why if but when I don't get
seasick on a roller coaster the reason I
love it is because I feel like I'm
simulating near death without being
anywhere close to it right also for
things like coffee it's like the initial
taste of coffee is very bitter it's not
it's not something you would like and
again so this is just an acquired taste
that's an interesting extrapolation
though it's an it's so this is that the
guy is saying a brain on an inner brain
psychological level that's something
that's happening now they he didn't
actually talk about acquired tastes
because I I did that that would have
been my explanation that's like you know
the more you eat the more you like it
but again the pigs and the dogs don't
know it's going on so we got into this a
little bit when we talked about
pickiness right so and which is I find
this interesting because you can rattle
off a lot of things that are
traditionally thought of is like not
good
blue cheese right blue cheese is a prime
example of something that like it's very
polarizing I don't like it it tastes
like rotten cheese because essentially
that's what it is and I absolutely love
it right it's just this bite and I did I
love it but we don't when it comes to
like roller coasters we're both just as
willing to ride a roller coaster it's
not like you're afraid to ride roller
coasters but you don't like blue cheese
you don't like olives spicy mustard or
whatever super hot stuff I think
something I I think the it's the I I
don't think olives is really a in
pickiness it kind of goes a little too
broad because I think your licorice I
think you licorice like okay you know I
don't things that haven't experienced oh
she ate it with liqueurs but I also
don't experience
associated with the bitterness of coffee
which they did talk about so I guess
okay yeah licorice it's something that
you're on a on a deeply instinctual
level it's like oh my gosh this
shouldn't go into my mouth because it's
going to your brain singing noise from
an evolutionary stable is gonna
contaminate you because it's bitter like
poison because the thing is is it just
so when you enjoy snot
but it's somebody who enjoys licorice
black licorice in the saltiest I have
some of that some I Aki and in my office
probably still saying that wrong it's
not like when I eat it I'm tasting
strawberries you know it's not like when
I'm eating it like I'm tasting something
that's like sweet and good I'm chasing
something that tastes like I'm biting
into a root that I pulled out of the
ground like I the bitterness it's for me
this is why I think it's I it's it
really and you're all in the brain
you're relating to this is because I
think that when I taste licorice I'm
essentially tasting the eggs and now
everybody's taste buds are different I
understand that there's different
amounts and different sensitivities and
they're super tasters etc but I don't
think that what it's just like people
right how do you know that I see green
and you see what you're agreeing and the
lyric from the thoughtful guy why do you
know that we see cell colors in the same
way yeah well because we have no reason
to believe that we see colors
differently because the same DNA
structure you know the same genes that
contribute to your visual apparatus or
the same kind of genes that contribute
to mind so okay is really right you're
saying most people taste liquor okay you
taste licorice the same as me but your
brain has a different perspective on it
because there's masochism thing so I
mean benign masochism is not it's not a
rational thing I think is it's a
subconscious thing that's happened
clearly but can you can you start to
pull from that subconscious when you're
eating the licorice can you can you
filter that experience through I don't
know
die no but I think I can I can put into
like smelling like smelling a fart
okay you know sometimes you you
and you smell it and you're like that's
horrible but you're like I keep smelling
that yeah I think like you you know you
are you know who's done that
and somebody else as far I've never
savored someone else's fart let me just
be very clear about that you savor your
own in that all mine just sometimes I
feel like maybe you're learning
something maybe your subconscious is
learning something it's you know it's if
I think Jade smells
she smells her own poop well dog and I
think she has learn dog have been
learning something dogs like to roll out
her own health drug dogs like well
that's trash that's different that's
that's more of like a camouflaging thing
but but smelling your own poop not
eating it but smelling it some dogs eat
it they talk about that in the podcast
too I think I think she's learning
something about her own health it's kind
of like sending your fecal sample off to
like some sort of doctor which
incidentally I think I've shared this I
have the fecal sample kit at my home
ready to be filled up oh well let me not
help you with that I will be telling you
all about it why I do it
why because I went to a new doctor and I
said I want the full rundown I want
everything I want bloodwork he's like
you want a fecal sample thing what well
of course is that is that that's an
option that sounds fun what of course I
want that I just wanted to be thorough
cuz you're a hypochondriac I want to
know I want a full evaluation and I kind
of liked the idea of being in my
bathroom and putting my poop into
something and shipping it to somebody
he's go to this doctor he's very
thorough he's very thorough I asked him
okay can I go outside to do this I'm
gonna be in the front yard
cuz man you you know the open air human
feces is one of the worst things in the
world
it's worse than bear worse than bear so
I think the question is are we benign
masochists I you know are you buying it
as far as I don't think I am in in
normal life like I just I've acquired
the taste of coffee I acquired and I'm
still
use that phrase acquired the taste in
college it was very late for me I dare
me as well oh yeah I tasted it when my
mom let me drink her coffee I have like
a vivid memory of tasting or coffee when
we lived in Thousand Oaks oh I would
have been as before I met you so I would
have been like five four or five and in
being like whoa and it's like the first
time your parents you let you have a
little swig of wine you know oh when we
I mean and we've you know we're not
proponents to this but we've told the
story of like trying chewing tobacco
which is oh that's easy
li-ming's one of the worst things that
you can try to put in your mouth and the
fact that people do it habitually I mean
there it well it's addictive because
there's an excuse but you like that - I
mean that that I did not like it if you
liked it and hated it at the same time
but the reason why was because it was
social pressure it was illegal it was it
was stupid
and it was it was wrong it was forbidden
yeah but for me I'd have to admit I
think that's a four with nine Manickam
when you were sitting out on one of
those rocks in the middle of the Cape
Fear River and it was super hot and we
were sitting there spitting - the water
makes you a little delirious and that
feels weird and like wow this is a
different experience no we do not we're
not proponents of that you shouldn't do
it it's a horrible or not do it horrible
like idea.i
my stomach turns just thinking about it
right now but I think it's a different
form of benign masochism that's like I'm
motivated by another factor which is I
know this isn't going too well long-term
it will kill you
but short-term it's not going to kill me
right now in it but if but it feels
illicit well so so it relates a
rollercoaster thing but I do not when I
think about the things that we've done
on the show it isn't this is not the
same thing for me I but I think maybe
because we go so far into the extreme
like if you take like surstromming as an
example you know the fermented Swedish
whatever it is some kind of fish yeah
absolutely horrible the kind of thing
that like when we open it in the studio
everyone has to evacuate you don't have
to eat it you just had to get close to
it we didn't even attempt to taste it
but if we open it now I bet you we would
and I think that's that's what I want to
get out but would you but I wouldn't
enjoy it I wouldn't I'm gonna do it I'm
gonna do it because it's the spirit of
our show is to try things and but I'm
not trying it thinking you know what I
might like this even though that's kind
of the unspoken premise or sometimes the
spoken premise of our show is will it
whatever is like is was this gonna be
unexpectedly good but I don't go into
those situations thinking of it the way
that I think about like okay sushi as an
example I we didn't grow up eating sushi
a lot of people our age didn't grow up
eating sushi but especially where we're
from mm-hmm so the first time I've ever
had sushi it was weird
the wasabi was a completely new taste
the eating ginger was all that was
completely new and exotic and I didn't
really like it the first time and then
kind of liked it the second time and in
third fourth time I was in and now I can
actually find myself craving it right
but and I think that I don't I just
don't see what we I don't know if that's
but not benign masochism I do think that
there is acquiring a taste for something
through another means that isn't the
pleasure of feeling like you're going to
harm yourself but you're not I think
there are other routes to changing your
mind over time about something but I
would like to look back I kind of like I
said I traced good mythical morning in
terms of how do we get to a point where
we started eating so much food and we
start you know it's interesting that it
hasn't what what what you said is that
there's not a component of it that we
actually enjoy it
we don't actually enjoy in the moment
eating this stuff that we're gagging
that's why we gag it out but I mean I
enjoy every other aspect of it I enjoy
every other aspect also don't feel sorry
for us don't feel sorry don't make
comments where you say things like if
you guys don't enjoy it don't do it we
enjoy most people do enjoy watching us
not enjoy
so and we don't shy we're gonna keep
doing we enjoy our audience enjoying
that we're not enjoying it and that
makes us enjoy it and when I watch those
montages of us trying to get things down
and not being able to I mean it is
you've seen the way that I reacts in the
moment when you can't get something done
I mean it brings me joy I mean III that
there is pure joy in watching your best
friend not be able to get food down
that's great there's a lot of joy in
that I was surprised at how we got to
this point so it perhaps as a digression
I just I just wanted to take us down
memory lane because I always tend to
think of Willett as you know we we we
did an episode called Willett tako we
did that episode on Cinco de Mayo
of 2014 okay um almost five years ago
and I went back and I watched part of
that you know just hard shells and we
just put stuff in it like broccoli and
cheese I made a comment on that episode
before we ate pork blood congealed pork
blood and like little cube long tube
logs of it I said this is why we're on
the Internet
this is our destiny like I said better
you're a prophet just really really
stupid I shouldn't have said that but I
tend to think that like that's the
moment where this thing started to
careen into crazy that was season five
episode 82 so I went all the way back to
the beginning it's like why don't we
really start eating stuff season 1
episode 5 we did best candy bar ever and
then maybe a month or two later we did
best cereal ever we were trying
different best evers and we were like
doing toys and all types of stuff it
didn't catch so even though very early
on we did eat some stuff and rank it
which we came full circle on that right
we abandoned it that's all we did
ate those two things
season 1 season 2 episode 76 was the
next time I could find us eating
something they would discontinue
Twinkies and we we said we we acquired
one I never eaten a Twinkie so we so how
o was that - the last Twinkie on earth
it was a fresh twinkle but it but the
company was gonna go over it was rescued
and there's between he still go under
even yeah it's only thing we ate in the
season 2 season 3 episode 29 I was
playing a game with you about like ways
to extend your life and every time you
got a question right I'll let you take a
bite out of a quadruple whopper how
about just cuz I thought that would be
funny we had the good ideas back then do
we well we didn't know what was
happening I mean I just wanted to eat a
Quadra viewer and you loved it you were
eating this you would get a question
right you would just chop on this
quadruple whopper and it was a great
thumbnail - well of course that that
didn't really click into place the only
other thing we ate in season 3 there's
an episode called rhett and Link eat
insects and I think that was I didn't
watch that one but I think it's probably
like fans sending us like crickets in a
bag or something I honestly didn't watch
it that's the only thing we ain't in
season 3 then we made the mythical show
and then we came back in season 4 no
food on the mythical show not that I not
that I recall
interesting that we had not yet
understood that definitely shows that we
didn't understand the potential that
there was now I'm eating on camera the
fact that we created this show that we
had such high hopes for Ryan didn't eat
a thing now well that maybe we did now
will it taco again with season 5 but I'm
just starting season for everything that
I could find in a cursory search that we
ate I'm sure there's a little bit more
but not a whole lot we did to think of
the habanero pepper challenge I think
that's where we ate increasingly hot
peppers getting up to the habanero mmm
it's before hot ones existed we did that
once then we did it we did something
called the noodle showdown in Ephesus in
seizes it for where we ranked different
types of noodles like you know
torn tournament-style then we never did
that again it's so fascinating to me
that like we did this what why would we
want to taste noodles Oh at that point
we're really we were already trying to
figure out we were out about what to do
yeah we did an epithet peel that the
taste trippin pill yeah where it makes
sweet things sour and sour things sweet
cuz we were big on experiments like
that's how we thought of our show we're
not really eating things we're only eat
things if it's if it's part of an
experiment or for inventing something
because we did we invented the big mac
and cheese and like put an orange
chicken on a sub that seems more recent
know season four and four then we ate
the ghost pepper to follow up with the
habanero challenge we did a Ghost Pepper
episode and then we did one called the
strangest candy on earth we just got
international candies and we just tasted
them and talked about that's all we mean
out of all those episodes in season four
those are all the ones that our food
base that's it yes that's all I could
find
season five we started to started get
going a little bit we did we tasted fake
bacon mhm and then a few episodes later
we did an exotic meat taste test and
then we started like putting sriracha on
stuff and eating it we got some of that
cat poof coffee and tried that I said
cat poof but it was cat poop I was made
of some butter we did a blackberry taste
test with strawberry seventeen again
this is an exhaustive list this is not
just highlights these are the only food
things we did then we did bug war which
was me eating a scorpion oh wow I gotta
like season 5 episode 57
that's like became our most viewed video
of all time because it was the thumbnail
of me holding up a scorpion and I
actually ate the whole freaking thing
but you see what got us to that point is
oh we ate some bugs the previous season
we had some exotic meats then we did a
pizza taste test
after we we just did that out of nowhere
I mean I'm sure BuzzFeed was doing their
stuff too and there was a lot of feeling
like we're getting on each other's
bandwagon or something that was starting
to happen I don't know if we were
uh you think we were on the radar at
that point that that season maybe I
don't know season 5 is when GM has
started to take off I think we ate 40
year old ham and eggs and then we did
will it taco then after that in season
five we only did two more food episodes
I could find after will it taco we did
fly in waffle which was unidentified
flying waffle we invented some we try to
invent other dishes like we did big mac
and cheese the last season that didn't
work so we abandon that and then we did
the squeezable food taste test where we
fired food at each other oh yeah which
was a lot of fun but that was just like
a weird one off because we were doing a
bunch of like experiment stuff and again
we didn't really think of it as a food
thing that's all we did it the next
season we did Willet Ice Cream Sandwich
because in our I'm on vacation video we
were we played guys who worked in an ice
cream sandwich factory and so we came up
with that idea in order to promote
people watching our music video you and
we were like oh we did well at Taco many
months earlier so May of 2014
let's see June okay
it was a it was only a month later we
started it was it was early with maybe
the beginning of season six yeah so we
followed that up and then all of a
sudden we started to do some stuff but
again I can quickly tell you everything
we did in season six it was food smell
tasting will it double awesome deep that
wasn't food actually will it deep fry
and then we did the Carolina Reaper do
you know I have 25 million views yeah
that's because a bunch of people keep
crazy watching it September of 2014 them
guess that exotic sausage we did that
four episodes later then we opened the
surstromming with pewdiepie and a good
mythical more we did will it cereal
started doing a bunch of other Willits 3
episodes later we did blind fast-food
burger challenge that's when we started
getting in that blindfold at door
together identifying stuff and we
started you see the slippery slope of us
starting to eat ate more exotic or weird
foods it it it was interesting to mom
like Willet taco did not click in our
minds that we were immediately gonna
start doing Willits
like we do one every month now but that
took a long time to get going cuz the
third one we did was will it double
awesome hmm
cuz we we started doing experiments
about like giving yourself hiccups so we
would like start to drink a whole bunch
of hot sauce we just started to become
much more willing to put things down our
throats in order to experiment and find
stuff out well maybe that's not the best
way to put it
okay so what what we were doing just to
put it bluntly is we were without even
really knowing it or you know
acknowledging it at the time we were
doing it was kind of our personal
version of what has happened with the
media with online media mm-hmm in
general so we became but we became these
Daredevils and we didn't even know it
was happening well specifically what I'm
saying is that okay so now the news the
way that the news works is it's based on
advertising right so I mean I'm not
saying anything that you don't already
know but basically a lot of people are
sort of saying that you know journalism
is ultimately dead if something doesn't
change because ads are what is fueling
the journalism industry and so what do
you need you need eyeballs
you don't truth is not important
eyeballs are important so therefore
you're going to title your article in a
way that gets people to click and you're
probably gonna be willing to do
something that's misleading right now we
weren't doing it the thing we were
always concerned about making sure that
when you clicked on something it wasn't
misleading so it's not right name but so
we had to actually put it in our mouth
what we're doing more peein and then not
eat it the news industry has been
completely transformed because I think
people to click our lives because we
were the ones personally putting
ourselves into this situation our GI
tract has been has been chance that we
were talking the other day about what is
this and this is why I'm getting my poop
analyzed
and you should too I should I'm getting
my microbiome analyzed because I want to
know what's in it man
and I think it's going to be drastically
different than it would have been before
all this stuff happened because of the
stuff that we put in our bodies but
that's what we're doing we were
responding to a trend when we would go
back and we would look at a season and
we would decide what what are we gonna
do again I was like well one of the
factors was well these things got views
people seem to care about this so we got
to keep doing those things and we're and
we're good at it we can't we
instinctively know how to contextualize
experimental or weird or gross foods and
also in and then on the backside of that
somehow we became guys like to every
every man who can say if I eat a burger
blindfolded can I tell you what it is or
not you know just because it's it's just
interesting to people and we're like
okay but I just wonder if like johnny
Knoxville or like the Jackass crew like
do they have is is their actual
masochism going on with them or are they
and it's like if we were to talk to them
but they may in a similar place of
elicit I've listened to a few johnny
Knoxville interviews I think I like the
guy I'd like to meet him I'd like to ask
him but I don't remember gleaning that
knowledge if I just get a sense that
like are they just doing it for the for
the for their version of clicks or
adulation or you know entertainment
value do they actually enjoy it there's
such a thing as a masochist I I think
that it well I don't first of all
they're in a completely different league
well yes with what they're willing to do
to themselves absolutely in fact the
links that they go to are things that
the average good mythical morning viewer
would probably be uncomfortable with and
there's probably not an incredible a
crossover between the two audiences even
though we put ourselves under duress all
the time
well the KIC really and I think I said
before that like that I cannot watch the
coyote Peterson get stung or bit or not
and I think that not I could not watch I
view but do you
watch jackass not much would you same
thing apply like seeing somebody get hit
in the nuts or I mean they started
seeing somebody get attacked by a lion
while I'm in a zebra costume I mean they
do that's the kind of thing they do I
mean I also don't watch other people I'm
I've only watched other people eat hot
peppers because they wanted to watch
them of course I don't you know I don't
really watch a lot of stuff but I don't
watch people he gross things either like
it it the thing that we've arrived at
when it comes to eating gross foods the
only point of reference that I
personally have all the few episodes of
Fear Factor that happened to be on
television way back in the day where
they would force them to eat nasty stuff
as like a physical challenge so that's
really the first yeah I think from in
terms of us culture but I'm sort of our
first exposure to that but it phenomenon
it's interesting that it it's something
that we just had these couple of weird
ideas and only because they worked it
evolved into this thing what we weren't
emulating anybody and we weren't
entertained by anybody else doing
anything comparable yet we found that we
find ourselves in this position and now
you're you're wondering has it impacted
your your inner biome well because I
know how it impacted us because I also
don't eat it's changed the way that I
eat in general because I feel like well
when we make the show I eat basically
whatever I want and you know me like if
we're doing a pizza taste test or
whatever I'm like a cow man I just I
look over there I'll just eat the whole
piece with I have a handful of whatever
it is we're eating I look over to you
and it's gone I'm like yeah and it's not
a conscious no way I'm just I'm a big
man I'm a big man I'm a hungry man I
like I run hungry
there's such a thing as running hungry
like it like my leg oh my level of cargo
is even though you're the one who's
always like where's lunch I'm actually
the one who's hungry III just I'm always
hungry and so I just eat so but I
thought I'm putting these things in my
body when we make the show so I probably
shouldn't put these things in my body
when we're not making the show so I try
not to
fried stuff I try to limit my meat
intake I remember talking to all our lot
and like I mean and he was talking about
how he eats healthily when he's not
doing Epic Meal Time like it at the
height of Epic Meal Time we had this
discussion and he was yeah you have to
we went out to dinner with him and he
was like I don't yeah I'm gonna get a
salad I'm kind of gonna eat like a like
a healthy choice because I'd do that cuz
I'm a human I go cuz we went to that
place next to VidCon in Anaheim that was
like burgers and hot dogs or whatever
and he was like I'm gonna get salad
right so it's nothing impact of the way
that I see food but hot foods I've been
scarred
I'm absolutely have there's no like
there's no chance of me getting on that
bandwagon because I've been rocked like
my brain has changed because of the the
experiences that we have with the
Carolina Reaper and the the Trinidad
Moruga scorpion
so that ship has sailed today that's
less because of what happens with you is
like you can smell it or taste it and
makes you like sick or whatever that
does happen to me whatever to me is it
was just so unpleasant especially I'm
the one who suffered the most from the
Trinidad thing I was out of commission
last time you were on the show but then
that night I was in just as bad a pair
we both threw up but to me it's just we
both forced ourselves to throw up so
that we wouldn't have to pass it the
other direction if this point was not an
easy thing to do because it was it was
just as hot when you when you threw it
up it's not like when it got in your
stomach it started to lose its hotness
well okay and so a lot of people have
said okay well there's now there's the
pepper X which is hotter than anything
that we've eaten why don't you guys eat
the pepper X well interesting there's a
reason for that because I don't want to
you think it's my reason well I I think
it's actually the there is a there's
variables involved right there's what is
the level of pain that we would go
through and then what is the reward and
then how much does the reward impact
where we're at so at this point
thankfully we don't need to have a video
that gets 20 million views in order to
be okay you know I'm saying like we've
gotten to a place where we have a
product that people like and we don't
have to do we don't have to put
ourselves through that much pain in
order to get noticed and so it's just
not worth it and also it wouldn't get
that many views because people have seen
people do all kinds of stuff now it's
not nearly as novel as it was if you
know what the pain that we would
experience is the constant in fact it's
probably actually increased because
we've gotten older so the amount of
discomfort that we would go through is
an all-time high and then the reward is
at an all-time low and that is why we
are not going to ever eat the pepper X
you don't need to keep asking us to do
it we're not gonna do it we don't have
to but we're not going to eating gross
stuff yes and you've never done this to
us yeah okay good rich well put our glad
you sit up after that put a stake in the
ground yeah we put a fist bump together
but when it comes to gross foods I've I
think I've learnt well we've learned a
couple of things like my brain I've
developed some skills like I'm really
good with AB live old like I can operate
with a blindfold in lots of environments
he where'd all the time now put that in
my like sleep with one my want ad good
with black fold call me what do you want
well I'm really we're I think we're both
really good at like tasting things that
have no business having the flavor they
have and guessing what it is like
blindly guessing in congruous flavors on
things because because that's happened a
lot over episodes we have done we've got
a lot of experience with like just
blindly guessing why something has a
flavor that it shouldn't have but then
also just the skill to be able to
participate in one of the most intimate
acts that a human could participate in
and that's consuming something wow what
an intimate I mean it was going inside
you I mean it really
I mean if you want to get down to like
the what's what what's happening I think
the reason why it's so compelling what
we and the other people who eat weird
stuff do is because like I mean the the
most intimate thing you can do with
something if put in your mouth I mean
it's one of the most intimate things I
mean it might be an emotion to me yeah
so it's like if that's gross and you're
willing to consume it or try to consume
it that is a feat and we have gotten
good at being able to do that like being
able to I mean the amount of time that
we would hem and haw before we would
like actually put something in our
mouths has drastically decreased like
we're almost nonchalant about it now
like we forget well and also in but
we're good at and going back to the
whole the variable is gross stuff it's
gross for a second it doesn't I mean
some stuff sticks with you a little bit
even if you disappear even in the worst
case it's the Tate you can get the taste
out of your mouth you can get a taste
out of your mouth right you can't
necessarily get that burn out of your
mouth in the same way or that burn out
of here Riley so I think continue
continuing to eat gross things it's I
think we've reached I hope Josh isn't
listening to this don't tell me about
this I think we've reached like
practically like the the ceiling yeah
but we're not how actually gross
something can be but we're not any I
don't know about that I mean I'm don't
feel like I'm any better for instance
I've said this repeatedly the congealed
blood ironically the first thing that we
ate that kind of started this whole
train this is the answer to the question
what is the worst thing you've ever
eaten I think it's got to be the the
blood because you know the reason I
don't the reason I don't like liver that
that reason is multiplied by a you know
exponentially with with the blood
because this got this metallic like it
just I know but instantly coats my mouth
and I kissed
I have this visceral reaction and it
immediately makes me gag I've seen you
on a pot like without pause or
discussion just bite into a heart like
an apple that wasn't a problem yeah I
and that's still a problem for me like
anything that like is an intact thing
that's nasty and I have a real hard time
with that like an eyeball or an in like
an entire organ like a kidney or a heart
those type of things but I have got a
lot better I've I've grown as a
performer it's just a weird it's just a
weird type of performance it's just I
mean I'm so fascinated that we like
careened I I don't know it didn't happen
that fast that's not the right verb but
as I as I how did it make you feel when
I when I when I tracked through the
ideas that we had it make you feel proud
as I don't know what you do some more
pride I'm not surprised by it at all
it's so weird right yeah but at the same
time I kind of feel like and I think
this has been proven when you know we've
initiated it's sort of the unofficial
initiation at least it was at a tie it's
a certain time for a new you know crew
members was having them eat something if
you go back and look at those things or
when we've had like a special guest like
a make-a-wish guest or you know when we
had the golden tea winner Megan Megan
she they all ate ate stuff like without
issues I don't I don't think that we're
especially good at it and eating it I
think we're especially good at reacting
to it I think that the thing that we do
this compelling is the way that we
engage with it but I don't think it's
that we have some incredible tolerance
for gross things I think Josh would show
us show us up oh yeah he can eat
anything the dude likes the blood he
prefers the blood well we've got an idea
you know we're flirting with an eye
I'll just you know give you guys a scoop
because hey you listened this far into
an ear biscuit talking about what if we
revisited some Willits and I think this
was an idea that some mythical beast
suggested as well so we are listening we
hear and we reconsider that I think
Stevie might have seen some comments
well because I'm so weird somehow we
would be able to do it in a way that
back in the day it was throw broccoli
into a taco but now we've got Josh and
he can actually make something that's
interesting unique and innovative in
some way so right I think we could we
revisited things you can't in a
completely fresh way can he make some of
the things that didn't will I think his
greatest challenge is can he make me
enjoy the blood that's really but I do
want to just quickly cuz I I found some
stuff that I think is will help Matt
well it helps to explain how we're gonna
map out the next years of our life and
how we're gonna relate to these things
because the good news is link we're
gonna get better
you think we're already pretty good at
eating this stuff well science is on our
side we are going to get better because
our taste is going to get worse oh okay
first of all I did not understand this
but okay so basically taste sensitive
cells are called gustatory cells
gustatory cells am a nap it's like the
name Gus and then to Tory gustatory
cells sure they're clustered within the
taste buds of the tongue the roof of the
mouth and the lining of the throat what
you can taste with your throat yes I
didn't know that did you know that you
can taste with the roof of your mouth
you should like no take your finger put
it on the roof of your mouth and see if
you taste it no let's let's make this in
episode this would be like a soup or a
good idea can you taste with just your
throat most people have around between
2,000 and 10,000 taste buds that's quite
a discrepancy quite a range but 9,000 is
a number I got somewhere else so 9,000 I
think I think it's closer to 10,000 for
most people now
your taste buds will begin to decrease
in number and also shrink and get less
effective the ones that remain get
crappier this happens between the ages
of 40 and 50 for women and 50 to 60 for
men it happens later for men so we've
actually like the 50 to 60 and then
after 60 those are gonna be the golden
years of tasting for us so a 45 year old
man has more taste than a 45 year old on
average I didn't say it after 60 many
people lose the ability to distinguish
between sweet sweet salty sour and
bitter foods so now you're getting into
a place where grandpa you know it's just
like the time that mush my grandfather
in law my brother-in-law was eating some
steak and he got some gristle and he
couldn't chew it and so he took it and
he put it on his plate and then my
grandfather Lauda's picked it up and ate
it Oh
because old man cannot distinguish
between grist between somebody else's
spit gristle and say texture man that
was just he's also a performant I don't
know if he knew that it had been a spit
out he just picked it off his plate name
and then it gets worse after 70 your
sense of smell begins to decrease which
is just adding to the fact that you've
got all these dying taste buds now you
can't even smell which is 80% of taste
and then what people start doing is they
start adding salt and sugar so they
could taste more which is in turn bad
for their health I think what this all
means is that people are just not meant
to live that long you know I think
modern medicine we're supposed to like
die like we're supposed to be about dead
right now
that's that's the humans are supposedly
about 40 45 50 like the cavemen and then
you're supposed to expire now we've got
all these modern conveniences and we can
just live forever but not taste we can't
hear we can't see we can't taste we
can't smell but that's a great time to
just really glean into this yeah I think
what is an after 70 man boy we're good
we're really gonna turn a corner I'm
just gonna good mythical morning always
be eating we'll be eating the testicles
right off of animals you thought that
was fun because anything will be exact
Joko you know
that that that far in advance you know
right actually what the reality is we're
gonna Lawrence this hologram of phone oh
these elderly people oh no you know it's
gonna happen because society changes in
societal norms change and what's
acceptable morally continues to change
we're gonna look back like they will
show videos of us eating testicles like
20 or 30 years from now and it'll be
like a shame and it would be like we'll
be in like a montage at the beginning of
a documentary about the decline of it
all started when people started getting
entertained by men eating animal
testicles and will be like you're right
sorry will go live in a cave what we
will grant an interview for the
documentary meadow we'll be in a cave we
won't speak to anyone will be publicly
shamed oh and we won't be able to taste
my bill I'm sorry it was a different
time it'll be like we don't care that
was a different time you should have
done it
did you bring sugar and salt okay well I
think the conclusion is as fascinating
is benign masochism is and it does apply
to certain things I do not think it
applies to us because really with yeah
in relation to the show up right right I
don't like I don't I'm not I've never
had a hankering to taste testicle yeah
me neither man that's the truth that's
the truth but no judgment if that's you
all right so there you have it a
culinary delight spread before you and a
table of a table of our choosing which
is round and dimly lit with a
recommendation gotta throw in a Rex in
effect because we try to if you hate it
all of that you still stuck around
because you want a recommendation I'm
gonna make this quick but I'm gonna
recommend an app we're still in the in
the the music loving genre
I recommend genius it's also a website
and so if you haven't heard of this it's
it's a it's a collective of users who
will then place commentary on lyrics
have you ever heard of this No
the app is yellow and it's it's called
genius genius and it's not genius scan
no that's another app that's for
receipts so yeah I mean as an avid
partaker in hip hop I'm able to I need
translations like basically genius is a
translation for what understand the hell
they're talking about in in hip hop
these days doesn't mean between all the
mumbling and all of them all the codes
it is they rapping code right and if
this 40 year old out-of-touch dude is
going to understand it and fully
appreciate what's happening I lean on
genius yeah and they have a the reason
is it all lyrics or is it hip hop in
general all lyrics any any song that
you're curious about the meaning or any
and people will up vote and so like the
best user-generated commentary what kind
of rise to the top so it's not it's it's
got this wiki vibe that it's not 100%
reliable but you can kind of tell okay
you know so it it definitely helps shed
some light on I mean it's basically all
of hip-hop is code is what I've learned
from from from the app and if you're
listening on Spotify sometimes on your
phone they'll have like genius will come
up and add like a pop up video layer on
all like I learned like the back story
about that you know the song Africa
because I was just listening to on
Spotify and the genius pop ups started
coming up on the video which is pretty
cool I just found myself watching genius
via Spotify on my on my phone listening
to music cuz I'm in a tap so that's the
wreck if you're into that then go check
it out and if you think you know stuff
about lyrics you can submit stuff again
not a sponsor just a rag
you know just give recs man we just give
recs stuff that we'd like alright that's
all I got thanks for hanging out with us
are you hungry go get you something to
eat
think we've talked about anything that
would generate an appetite something
vinegar almonds oh yeah those are good
don't give them to the kid - hashtag ear
biscuits let us know about your
experience with benign masochism or
don't you know what it is now yeah yeah
just tell us what how you see food gross
for yes just in the foods to be more
suitable yeah
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best